john gruden used racial trope to
describe nfl pa chief
uh the maurice uh smith in 2011 emailed
the wall street journal on july 21 2011
national football league and his players
were working to resolve a lockout that
threatened the upcoming season that they
the league owners voted to ratify a new
collective bargaining agreement but the
players opted not to vote on it
immediately citing outstanding issues
that the union was fighting to resolve
the same that same day john gruden the
current las vegas coach
raider coach who has been one of the
most prominent figures in the nfl over
the past two decades sent an email to
demaria smith
the executive director the nfl player
association to
a team executive gruden's email
described smith was a racist trope
common in anti-black imagery
uh dumb uh dumb dumbora smith has lips
the size of a michelin tires he wrote in
the email the nfl is reviewing gruden's
status with the raiders for potential
discipline yesterday the tweet comes out
and saying uh that adam schafer i think
came out and said he is probably gonna
step he's gonna get fired and then
announcement was made that he resigned
yeah uh and john gruden is no longer the
head coach of the raiders which they
were off to a decent start
uh and
there's couple other stories that came
out as well but that's what i'm going to
stop right here if you got any comments
adam i'm going to start with you first
well
this really resonated with me when i saw
randy moss uh
weigh in on this over the weekend did
you see randy
break down in tears
look uh i think the nfl is 70 black
okay um
it's clear that
i don't know less than 20 of the nfl
coaches are black
i don't i think it's 10 percent of the
gm or the front office that are that are
black
and
this was just i'm not saying that john
groon's a racist i am saying that he's a
[ __ ] idiot
um
he completely lost
his locker room if if
what's al davis's son's name mark davis
okay they were known for the bad boys at
the nfl but this is not the bad boys
that you want to be
these days okay so he's lost the locker
room if 70 of your team is black how do
they even respect you at this point you
know what you're doing when you're
calling dumb morris smith and using
racist tropes like huge lips or the size
of michelin tires apparently he was also
using some anti-gay slurs about michael
sam the gay guy that was
um rams that was drafted by the rams he
was talking
major crap about roger goodell calling
him a
p-u-s-s-y and a f-a g-g whatever
whatever um i'm sure he's the first
person ever that called gold no i'm sure
well goodell gets hated on a lot but i
think at the end of the day he was a
complete distraction and if he stayed on
his coach this is something that the
raiders will be dealing with all year
and i don't think it's a uh
i don't think it's ironic that they've
lost their last two games since this has
kind of been out in the in the news and
they lost to a
not that good of a bears team with a
rookie quarterback over the weekend he's
lost the team and he had to go
okay
listen um
we saw with brett kavanaugh listen
and in your interview with the facebook
moderator the fact that anybody can read
any message that's ever been on any
facebook platform whatsapp instagram uh
if we're all gonna be adjudicated for
[ __ ] that we said 10 11 12 years ago
there's gonna be a lot of people that
got a lot to [ __ ] answer for boy let
me tell you all right and
i'll also say
and i'll be controversial okay
black people are not a protected species
you can't just say
that he said something that was can be
construed as racist and that's a career
death sentence all right especially in
in a league
where
[Music]
desean jackson said anti-semitic things
no desean jackson
said anti-semitic things that were the i
mean he he quoted a man who who quoted
hitler
he didn't lose his job in the league he
quoted fair economically yeah he didn't
lose his job in the league i mean i i
think that what john gruden did is
stupid inadvisable he thought that what
he was saying was private he was
probably trying to be edgy in a private
conversation also sent
uh naked photos of women and stuff like
that
it's a bad look it's a bad look for the
guy who's the ceo of the organization i
get all that but he should have never
apologized first of all because the
people that have a problem with this
stuff they're never going to be like
okay well he apologized he's going to
learn from it no never freaking
apologize that's number one never back
pedal if you believe in your heart of
hearts that you're not actually racist
if you believe in your heart of hearts
that you're not actually misogynist and
this is just the language that you grew
up in the times that you grew up in then
explain it like that all right but as
soon as you backpedal as soon as you
apologize you give credence to your
accusations okay that's number one
number two if the nfl
is really has a problem
with
uh homophobic slurs
and misogyny
then how in god's name is snoop dogg
eminem and dr dre
the halftime
performance this year why'd you take my
[ __ ]
i'm just saying if you're saying if you
really have a problem and i love eminem
and i love dr dre and i love snoop
dogg's music okay but if this is really
an issue then how are they your super
bowl half time there's a difference
between a performer who comes in for 15
minutes
just call it what it is there's a
difference
in a black guy just say what it is i
don't think that's what it is i think if
a black guy said this about white people
he'd be fired too
desean jackson we literally just showed
you what happened that's a one wide
receiver this is the face of your team
you have to leave you have to be coaches
are facing the team of the raiders for
sure they just they brought him out of
the announcing booth he hasn't coached
in 15 years okay and they made him
everything and everything for the
raiders so to your point it's not like
he's some screw up wide receiver that
goes from here
he's not a scrub that guy's been on 12
teams in 12 years right so you got
gruden 10 years 100 million
they're like let's get them out of here
so we can save some money i don't know
three and two right is the record that
they currently have
look this is back in july
of 2011. this is [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] you're bringing up stuff
from like 10 years ago of this stuff
like if it was that damn serious people
do what they want to do
if you really thought this was an issue
you would have done something
then what you should have done so roger
goodell all you people that were
involved raise your hand and say i
didn't really care about it 10 years ago
but i sure do now and explain because we
need an explanation
because you know what if they pulled up
something from me 10 years ago
they say phil you thought this way i'd
be like yeah back then but i don't do
now and and no like at the end of the
day what gerard's saying is right
you run a sports organization
okay when you have certain people
perform
at the biggest event pretty much in our
country which is the super bowl right
billions of dollars involved
and you have people
like eminem that have said the word
f-a-g-g-o-t plenty of times
and the stuff that snoop dogg has said
plenty of times
you got to call a spade a spade here it
is adam this is spade you're going to
call it or not because they are
representing your brand during that time
if they were
okay let me ask you this if r kelly
wasn't
you know behind bars would you and he
was uh supposed to do the super bowl
what were your thoughts would be
you say hell no he's not representing
the nfl this and that and the other but
you got these guys representing the
super bowl there you go eminem from 2012
ready i may fight for gay rights
especially if the dyke is more of a
knockout than janae rice play nice [ __ ]
i'll punch lana de rey in the face twice
like ray rice in broad daylight in plain
sight of elevator surveillance to the
head is banging on the railing then
celebrate with the ravens
[Music]
and what's name one thing and what team
does the eminem coach
he's performing for the entire state so
let me proceed let me let me hang on i'm
trying to i'm trying because there is a
point here so what you're saying is the
comment
is irrelevant it's the status status of
the individual making the comment is
what you're saying okay so you're saying
a player can get away with making any
comment at all and a rapper can get away
with it but not a head coach that's what
you're saying i did not say any comment
a player can't get away with anything we
saw what happened with um
the guy on the heat uh who's he said
some uh to luca montrose hero no no um
what was the the center um miles uh he
said something anti-semitic right yeah i
forget his name what happened to him he
was released from the team he was
injured he's gone okay players can get
it too you gotta understand if you're
the coach of the team yeah nfl is very
fickle if it's if the sentiment of the
team
or if the mood of the team sways a
little bit they're looking for heads to
roll so i got a few this is the coach of
the team i don't i'm saying this i think
you make a good point there and i think
that's something to process to say a
leadership person
is held to another leonard is the guy
i'm thinking about okay so now you're
ready now you're ready for this now
you're ready for this okay
when he said it was he a head coach
he was an announcer i believe that so
he's not so so he didn't he never made
that comment as a head coach he made
that comment as an announcer but wait
let's let's let's okay let's go through
each he made that comment as an
announcer working for who at the time he
was a former nfl coach who wasn't
working no no he was the coach of the
temple
they won a super bowl and but who would
three
you don't think espn knew about that
i don't know maybe maybe they did you
know but wait a minute let's actually
process this you don't think espn knew
about that common made 10 years ago
i don't know okay i don't want to
speculate and say yes or no
are you leaning more towards yes or no i
literally don't know what yes but if you
were to play odds vegas gambling are you
leaning towards yes or no i i'm not what
do you think do you think espn new
no okay you think espn new
i don't think so just because i mean
where was the data located off of
someone's server or something yeah this
is an email this is a data lake this is
coming out because of uh sexual
harassment allegations within the uh
washington football team uh
there they've been
so you mean to tell me smith the the guy
he sent the executive the email to you
think he's kept it a secret for ten
years but he didn't he sent it to bruce
though he sent it to bruce and he's kept
it a secret for 10 years
maybe not okay i'm not convinced espn
didn't know you think yes been new i'm
i'm i'm 55 they know and i i'm convinced
espn is kind of like look guys this
cannot be tarnish and espn we are a
clean image there's no way this can come
out now he's a head coach of the raiders
100 million dollar contract 60 million
dollar guarantee all this other stuff
screw it you know let's now bring it out
because there's other stuff coming and
throw that email in there as well okay
cool so so people hang on to stuff for a
long time by the way just so you know
this isn't the first time that
somebody's hanging on to an email with
somebody you push a little bit too much
and he made some bad comments about
biden and obama
that's not let's not uh
can you go pull up what comments you
made about obama and biden but i'm going
to go to a different angle here i'm
going to go to a different so that's one
area i understand the coach thing when
you're a coach you have to be careful
with the words what you're saying let me
go to the next part especially when
seventy percent of your players if not
more are black when he made the comment
he worked for espn espn should have
fired him if they knew about it it's
important to mention this though and i
do believe him when he says this because
in the email
he praised gene upshaw who is black if
he really meant demar smith the maurice
smith
uh as uh you know this was like a racial
mind he he
this guy's lying right
and in the context
of the the context of the rest of the
email it makes sense he's talking about
him as a liar i have to state one fact
here how old do you think john gruden is
he's 58 years old he's 58 so these
emails that came out seven ten years ago
he's a 50-year-old man
okay making these dumb ass comments
talking to his friend i don't care who
he's talking to you're a head coach
you're a face of the nfl it's not like
he's 18 like if someone's 16 18 20
and they make some dumb stuff they have
some time to grow up i know your mother
i know your mother was a 50 year old man
i know your mother wants to be a rabbi
i probably stay worse stuff on camera
than i disagree guys let me let me go to
my next point let me go to my next point
okay fine you're saying he was 50 years
old here's my next point he made a few
comments about uh obama and biden if you
can find that well are you saying you're
defending john gruden where do you
what's
next point is this what's the value of
an apology
nothing
nada zip zilch what zero what is the
value of an apology to you i i tend to
agree with gerard that apologizing is
just nothing i won't say it means
nothing but i don't you know what you
know what is very irritating is because
when
when commentators who defend players who
are about to get fired they say give the
man a break
we've all made you know he at least
apologized what are we here judging this
man we've never done anything before so
everything is about the argument that
makes sense so delta mantras harold said
[ __ ] ass white boy to lucas how how how
good of a ward is that by the way i mean
if you want to go through it that's as
bad as it gets okay i've been called a
bitch-ass white boy in the basketball
court
ten thousand shots should montres harold
be uh fired
no but he's just one player i think
there's you have to distinguish between
a player like a deshawn jackson type
yeah or a myers leonard
or the head coach of a team who's
leading a man that's mantras harold is a
grown man he's a grown man the moment
you're that age you're a grown man over
you're a grown man you're no longer a
kid he's not a leader he's a he's a
leader for his he's a leader for his
community player no that's not how this
works you can't change standards on
different people brother
the standard for coach and a player is
the same thing what standards oh no i
totally did okay so that's on you though
by the way it could be a one group you
could have zero standards
then it has nothing to do with the
comment so you're saying lebron james is
not the leader you're gonna say the best
player of all time other than michael
jordan is yes he's a leader the tour of
the coach right yes the 12th man that's
like what manchester the 12th man on the
bench is not a leader pat it's very
clear all right and adam you've won me
over it's very very clear that what
mantras harold did was mostly peaceful
whereas these emails are clearly an
insurgency into
you know something that yeah
if you're gonna if you're gonna lead men
you need to you need to set an example
okay gruden reportedly aimed homophobic
slurs at godel in several instances as
well as using the offensive language to
describe nfl owners coaches and media
even barack obama joe biden will
reportedly mention in gruden's email
with gruden ripping obama during his
2012 re-election campaign and referring
to biden
referring to violent biden as a nervous
clueless
what would those other four letters
after pb i don't know but anyways pixie
yeah pixie so so look all i'm saying is
if if you're going to put the standards
of words it's got to be across the board
i disagree well yeah you're you're good
you have the right to disagree with that
but if you're going to say award is that
offensive to a sport stay consistent
roger goodell i am show us a level of
consistency so any player that says
something you're cut you're what i'm
trying to
i don't think you should
i don't think you should cut the guy i
think when you're in you know that
environment i don't think you should
okay
coaches are most coaches like very
proper 20 000 coaches yeah how are
coaches
loud mouths
you know who's scared right now you know
who's scared right now
the ryan coach who's the ryan coach
rex ryan's got to worry right now you
know what's got to worry 90 of these
guys got to worry right now what they've
said so what are you going to do
everybody you know what just happened
last 24 hours in the last 24 hours
probably 7 million emails have been
deleted in the nfl oh my god i didn't
shred it shred it all right dude
everybody had a meeting and said delete
everything i was an all-state linebacker
my senior year and my coach called me
baloney tits every day in practice all
right so like come on i call you that
every day
but let's go find a guy i got to tell
you man and again this is controversial
i really don't care i'm sick of people
treating black people like they have no
agency i'm sick of it like oh god how
could he possibly have said something so
horrible what happens if you use the
n-word but i did it but what he did i'm
asking you and actually
if he did that he did fireball
yeah if you called someone uh a monkey
or an ape is that fireable is it okay
is that fireable
if you call them the n word that's
fireball though right okay but you know
so words do matter but he did not
do words matter more if they're said
from a white person to a black person
that's what i was going to say because i
mean i'm not even looking this as a
black and white well you made it well
they literally they are they are random
only one angle i agree right however
myers leonard is a white guy who is
saying how many times the snoop dogg
said the n word and he says performing
at halftime i mean that's all i'm saying
dude how many times well that's a whole
nother conversation we can have about
black people saying the n word you know
there's black people that
wholeheartedly disagree with black
people saying that and there's black
people saying no that empowers me it's a
whole we can go an hour on that topic
yeah but i like at the end of the day
there is a difference between a coat
like pat you're a ceo of a company yup
so use your example
is there a big difference between you as
the ceo or matt sapaula being the cdo
or alexis moody being you know marketing
direct whatever versus some random sales
person who just came to the organization
last year there's a big difference right
right right right right right chris
herrell is not a random student but but
there is a difference though montres
harold's not a random okay
i'm asking you in the business context
yeah there is a difference between the
ceo the c-suite executive and just the
regular sales person so so for
standards-wise there is do you think the
difference is
you think you really lost
there is some set of standards that's
why i gave you credence at the beginning
where i said i think we have to give
credence to your argument i said yes i i
just think there's a difference in being
a leader or a founder or a ceo but this
is a random sound but i think you have
to know when you're a player and you
have some of these players have more
followers than these coaches so that's a
great influencer not even lebron montres
harold
john gruden montreal some of these
players have more followers than coaches
they're an influencer you make a comment
like that i'm sorry you're also you're
that is a form of a leader that is a
form of an influencer that is a form of
an example ah what i know a lot of
[ __ ] models with millions and millions
of followers that's your community
though that is my community but i'm not
saying that they're leaders but their
leaders are taking their clothes off in
a space like we're still getting
if it's all just based on followers
absolutely like this if you want to but
but in only fans like you're you're
[ __ ] friends you're talking about
whatever whatever you're talking about
this community right you're saying
followers doesn't mean you're a leader
but the point the point in that
community is that's across the board no
one cares this is a sport there is a
regulator at the top who his name is
roger goodell who's the commissioner he
wants to clean house to say some of
these things are not expected accept it
you got to clean it up then you got to
keep that consistency across the board
very clear you can't just say you can
say but this person cannot say it you
got it
standard why they weaponize these emails
like this i mean especially during the
season i mean there wasn't like an
investigation where you know it took
some weeks on end and you know like
there's no system in place to say
hey hey john you know this is what we
present to you you know like uh we need
to really have a chat about this you
weren't working for
you know as a coach like what pat said
what how do you feel about this because
we haven't had and he could and john
green could say well i haven't had any
interaction like this over the past 10
years
so what are we talking about
what infractions do i have currently
with this organization well there's none
but 10 years ago you said this in this
and you know you called me a pu you know
whatever and
maybe you need some sensitivity training
this network okay so
by the way i mean what are we talking
about here like i mean do you think you
lost the locker room do you think i
don't think you lost a locker room i
mean like there would be more players
standing up and stuff like that i think
what happens i think definitely what
happens when this news comes out
look i'm 41 i'll be 42 this year i mean
we're all relatively you're the youngest
um
i'm not 23
i'm not 25
making 50 million or whatever
i could i could easily at me at 25 i
could say you know what i could hear
maybe from like a seasoned veteran like
you i should be pissed and maybe i just
follow i don't know
because that does happen in the locker
room anyway what happened what happened
to the coach of the jacksonville jaguars
urban
if there's anybody that's excited about
this news it's him
yeah he was all up in the news for two
weeks straight now he's no talk about a
guy who lost no people that guy lost a
lot okay so why because he got a lap
dance from a 25 year old he didn't come
back on the team on the team flight and
then he did that bs for example yeah
what's his what's his worst what what
urban meyer did or what john gruden did
well
honestly like if i was in the locker
room i'd be like i would
i i don't know if i would give a [ __ ]
about john which is worse
from a player's perspective from just an
actual human being's perspective see i
could give a [ __ ] if a coach called me
big lips
okay i'm just gonna say it but you care
that he got take care of someone if you
do you care if someone called you said
you you've said this before someone
making fun of you or whatever you're
saying i got a big big nose and big ears
i could give two shits
i could give two [ __ ] i'm just gonna
say it sorry
but for the f-word but
i could care less okay i've been called
all kind of stuff playing ball in
college in high school oh my gosh
back then you could actually have your
coach grab you
back in the 90s and stuff so what urban
meyer did was worse
i'm saying that meyer bailed on his team
yeah i think that was that because he
didn't take a flight back with this yeah
he didn't take it back
after a loss
why because he was getting drunk with
some chick he stayed at his bar he stood
at his bar i mean okay okay so i don't
have a huge problem with whatever bro
you're right i'd be it's i'd be more
upset if i'm if i'm if his wife what the
[ __ ] were you doing yeah but if i'm his
player
you're a ceo of a company
that's worth a billion dollars you might
do some [ __ ] like that this is employees
are gonna be like what the hell man like
you're not supposed to be doing that
you're supposed to be on the private
private back i gotta take the jet back
but you don't i've gotta take the jet
back that's what ends up happening so
urban wire urban meyer is worse in your
eyes than john i don't know if again
listen if if the team came out all right
and listen i'll give you this if the
team came out and they were like you
know what we can't be led by this man i
i'd say okay you know what don't you
think those conversations were taking
place according to the internally
according to i don't know davis son of
al davis badass dude fire the guy or ask
him to resign uh because i think there's
been some rumbling i think there was
pressure on the organization arguably a
top five receiver of all time breakdown
in tears
espn but it's a outside
i don't think it's inside the
organization i think the pressure came
from outside the organization i think
it's probably a little bit of both i
think you're right that it was
definitely outside get the goodells of
the world but i think internally they're
like nah how much is how much does uh
gruden walk away with
is it depends on how much was guaranteed
right 60 million right whatever like
that's the whole thing and if there's
any sport that is very cruel you pointy
nose [ __ ]
give me my 60 million yeah exactly i'll
take it
call me whatever you want to come don't
worry whatever don't worry bro i got you
i'll bring you up call me pointy all you
want you know what i'm saying
man this is crazy anyway we live in a
crazy world man can you imagine how
mildly toast every email from now on and
through the end of history is going to
be bro i have but what i guess here's a
different question
what's a uh what statue of limitation so
if you did it last year that's that's
wrong obviously last year
you did it you know pre-pandemic two
years ago that's that's that's still
relatively recent that's that's wrong
but five years ago is that
well is it four like what's like what's
the number of years that's exciting
i'll take what you're saying and i'll
take it a step further how about like
the words that we used 10 years ago that
are considered like slurs now we're just
everyday language ten years ago like you
talked about the f word like yeah we we
use that word all the time that f w f a
double g word and it had nothing to do
with being gay it just meant like you
were like uh you you were you were a
wimp i think that you know what i'm
saying i think the the three-letter word
of that was very used non-stop the six
letter word not as you have no idea used
that word before which word
bro that's it that's it get out
of the three-letter
sucker listen to me so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you